Speaker 1: . Let's go next to I don't
know if it's Nitin or Nitin from New York.
However it is pronounced, I hope that we
can figure it out. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, this is Natan here from
New York. The land currently Pennsylvania.
Speaker 1: That's still allowed.
Speaker 5: No problem. I just had
a quick question about from the history of
frivolous lawsuits. Yeah. What does he get
out of them? Like, why does he, like, typically
filing? You know, especially I remember him filing
around 65 or so frivolous lawsuits that were all
like laughed out left, right and center in court.
Speaker 1: But you're saying in
response to the 2020 election.
Speaker 5: As he aimed to do.
Speaker 1: So there's different categories of.
Speaker 5: Filings.
Speaker 1: For. Yeah,
there's different categories of these lawsuits.
The 65 or 63 or whatever the number was filed in
response to the 2020 election. He needed to
file those because he was raising money on,
I'm going to be doing this and I'm going to
be fighting to turn it over and whatever.
If he raises all this money and then files
nothing. It doesn't look quite so good. So
he was filing them because he was raising money
to do it. Now, the lawsuits where like he sues
big tech for 300 million or whatever the case
may be, those seem more like virtue signaling
than they are for for sort of like grifting
purposes. So you have to look specifically
at which ones you're talking about.
Speaker 5: Gotcha. But, you know,
but in general, like, you know, I looked up
his legal strategies and, you know, like,
for the most part, it's mainly about, you know,
harassing opponents just to intimidate them or
like, you know, using it as a stall tactic 100%.
Speaker 1: That is absolutely what it is about in
many cases. Many times it's countersuits
to prevent some lawsuit against him from
moving forward. There's like a real all of the
above sort of situation going on with them, but
they seem to be relatively ineffective,
at least in the last five years.
Speaker 5: Gotcha.
Speaker 1: Yeah. All right. Anything else today?
Tell it.
Speaker 5: Nothing else.
Speaker 1: All right. Very good. I appreciate the
call in your videos. Okay. Knitted knitting from
York. We're starting to get a bit of a delay that
was causing some awkward exchanges. I'm sorry I
wasn't able to get to everyone, but I will try
to do better next time. Really great hearing from
many folks in the audience. We are going to take
a quick break and the Friday show will continue.